-My first guest
is an Emmy-nominated actress
and a judge on
"America's Got Talent."
The new season premieres June
1st at 8:00 p.m. here on NBC.
Here's Sofia Vergara!
Sofia! Welcome back!
-How are you?
-Oh, my gosh.
I am great.
It is so great to see you.
Thank you so much
for coming back on the show.
-No, thank you for having me.
I'm still here in the same place
where you saw me last.
-Yeah.
-In the basement of my house.
-Your husband, Joe Manganiello,
was nice enough to come
on our show not too long ago
and introduced me
to a new family member,
which I totally love --
-Who?
-He stole the show -- Bubbles.
-Oh, oh, yeah.
-Now, look at this.
-Yeah.
-Unbelievable.
-Yeah, that's Bubbles.
She hates me.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean, Bubbles --
-She hates me.
-She does not like you? Bubbles?
I thought --
-No, no. I mean --
-I thought this was your dog.
-She was supposed to be for me.
-Yes.
-She was supposed to be my dog.
-And she arrived to the house.
And she -- I don't know. She
thought that she was for Joe,
and that's all she wants to do.
She's, like, you know,
after him all day long,
harassing him.
-[ Chuckles ] "Harassing him."
-It's an obsession
this dog has with him.
It's like -- It's horrific.
She hates me. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ] Horrific.
You actually -- But you were --
-Yes. Horrific.
She's super mean to me.
She bites me.
-This is mean to you?
-Yes, yes.
-She's so cute!
-But she's not.
She's not that cute in person.
She's old.
[ Laughter ]
She looks like a baby,
but she's like 8 years old,
so it's like 69.
So she's like
a lot older than me.
I'm 49.
-Sofia, you were trying
to be nice to her.
You actually, on Joe's birthday,
you made him --
This is an amazing work of art.
A Bubbles birthday cake.
-Well, yeah, 'cause I wanted
to make him happy.
[ Audience awws ]
-And that's so --
-I wanted to make him happy,
because, you know,
that's like -- that's his baby.
He -- Well, I have to say,
he treats her like she's a --
you know, a little
puppy baby dog,
like a little daughter he has?
But she insists of, you know,
like, behaving like a concubine
or like beast friends
or something.
It's like, she sleeps with him.
-Oh, my --
-She gets angry
when I walk in the room.
I mean, it's a whole thing now
in the house.
-She's almost making
an expression here, like,
I like the cake but I know that
you had something to do with it.
[ Laughter ]
Very interesting.
-I'm telling you she hates me.
-You guys are a great couple.
Now you've been married
for five years.
You do not have the same taste
in music, though.
-No, no, no, no.
I mean, sometimes yes.
But usually -- Usually, no.
Joe is a little more
out there than me.
You know, I just like
simple Latin music.
-No, but he loves metal, right?
He loves -- He's a metal head.
-Yeah. It's like music
that is coming
out of the devil's house.
-No, no, that is not --
-It's horrific.
-No, that's not
a way to describe --
[ Laughter ]
-It's like sometimes he puts it,
like, when we're in the car,
and it takes me, like,
some minutes
to realize why I'm having,
like, palpitations,
why I'm not feeling good.
I think -- I feel like
I am having, like, high blood
pressure or something.
And it's like, "God,
it's the stupid music
that is such --"
How can you drive
with this intensity?
-Yeah. Between that and Bubbles,
I don't know how
you're doing all this.
-No, believe me. I don't know.
You know, and the pandemic,
I was, you know, inside
this house with the two of them.
I mean, it was not fun.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say, though, by the way,
thank goodness you're on
"America's Got Talent."
You're fantastic on there.
And it was a crazy season
last season,
because Heidi got sick, right?
-Heidi got sick.
Simon got in
a horrific accident.
Like, he couldn't walk.
-Yeah.
-And it was, like,
a whole ordeal.
The pandemic happened.
-But you stepped up.
-You know, like --
-You stepped up,
and you were there.
-I loved it.
-Yes.
I was great.
-No, no, that's --
[ Laughter ]
That's not -- Yes.
That's not -- You were --
That's not really what --
I did mean that.
But I think you're good,
and we talked about this
last time you were on the show.
As a judge,
you are a good judge.
And I said, "Is it difficult?"
Because it's hard to let people
down if you don't like their --
-It's difficult.
-Their talent, yeah.
Yeah.
-It's hard, you know?
You want to be fair.
You realize, you know,
that this is, like, the moment
that can change
somebody else's life.
So you have to
take it seriously.
They can change their families'
life, their life.
So you want to be fair.
There's so many talent
out there.
There's so many also
horrific thing that shows up
in the stage that you're like,
"Why? Why are you here?"
[ Laughter ]
So you want to be fair.
-Yeah, you want to be fair.
But then last time,
you said that you have --
You don't like ukuleles.
You don't even want
to see a ukulele.
You said, so if that comes on
the stage, you don't want it.
-No, but that's nothing --
Like, I'm not going to
immediately cut them
because it's a "ukuleelee."
I'm not going to do that.
It's just that I realize --
-Ukulele.
It's a ukulele.
-Okay.
Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
So it's like, I just don't
want to, you know, listen to a
whole concert
of a "ukulele-ey," I mean --
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a ukulele-le,
either, but --
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, really? Really?
-I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
No, I'm sorry. No, you're right.
It could be.
But I don't want to --
I'm not sure if I would go to
a giant whole ukulele concert.
But they mix it up.
I mean, now --
-Yes. No, it's great.
The show is great.
I mean, I love the dancers.
I realize that, how much I enjoy
watching people dance.
I mean, I guess I'm Latin.
But I didn't know --
I mean, it's really my favorite.
-It's your favorite part?
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a peek at next week's
season premiere
of "America's Got Talent."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-He did this too many times.
All his hairs left.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-I love it.
-Sofia Vergara, everybody.
When we come back, Sofia and I
are going head-to-head
in a new game called
"Piece of Cake Trivia."